[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute geht es ein ganz ganz schnelles
gericht wir machen nämlich eine wok
nudelpfanne mit richtig frischen und
richtig leckeren zutaten und dafür
benötige ich einen esslöffel
sonnenblumenöl 500 gramm rinder verlebt
eine zwiebel 1 knoblauchzehe etwas
ingwer zwei teelöffel honig einen
teelöffel stärke 125 milliliter
gemüsebrühe 50 gramm balsamico-essig 30
gramm soja sauce 50 gramm orangensaft
einen halben teelöffel chili salz und
pfeffer fürs gemüse verwende ich einen
esslöffel sonnenblumenöl eine zucchini 2
möhren zwei pak choi
ich habe ich den gar sigrid und von käse
in der geschmacksrichtung chili minute
sesam und frühlingszwiebeln die zwiebel
und die knoblauchzehe habe ich schon
geschält jetzt werden sie fein gehackt
denn irgendwann den braucht man nicht
schälen ihr könnt einfach mit dem
messerrücken oder mit einem löffel hier
oben die hause und ein bisschen
zurückziehen und den dann auch schon
fein würfeln
nämlich das fleisch da habe ich jetzt
das filet endstück also die philips
spitze und entweder beratet jetzt im
ganzen und schneidet danach aber ich
finde jetzt ein bisschen cooler das ist
so direkt zu schneiden einfach feine
stücke ein bisschen fett lasse ich auch
dran und wenn ihr die pfanne vegetarisch
machen wollt dann lasst uns fleisch
einfach weg
jetzt erhebt sich das öl meine reisen
fahne richtig heiß und berater das
fleisch wirklich ganz kurz nur an von
beiden seiten ganz scharf und heißt so
bleibt schön saftig
[Musik]
das bereite ich hier noch die soße zu
ich nehme einfach noch mal ein bisschen
öl falls kein öl mehr in der pfanne ist
das fleisch habe ich rausgenommen kommen
hier die zwiebel knoblauch und ingwer
würfen rein und werden angeboten
bis sie schön glasig sind ich habe ich
jetzt schon mal den bock aufgesetzt und
las wasser kochen denn ich werde jetzt
zuerst den nudeln darin kurz garen und
später warmes gemüse zubereiten und die
zwischenzeit nutze ich jetzt immer um
schon mal gemüse vorzubereiten
ich werde das packt einfach kurz
auseinandernehmen und fein schneiden die
karotten habe ich schon geschält und die
zucchini werde ich auch noch in julians
streifen schneiden oder vogel
das hier ist packt ein asiatischer kohl
ich würde das glaube ich nur gern wissen
der oder dass ich glaub mal gelesen zu
haben männlich der vielleicht wisst ihr
es ja besser und den habe ich jetzt wie
gesagt schon gewaschen
da schneide ich jetzt das untere ende
ein bisschen keine weil es einfach
härter ist und oben lasse ich aber die
blätter immer ganz im ganzen
[Musik]
zu den zwiebeln gebe ich noch den honig
dazu der verleitung gericht und richtig
schöne milde süße das kann man das
bisschen karamellisieren lassen das
wasser kocht auch gleich also ihr seht
da arbeitet man einfach so ein bisschen
parallel dann gebe ich noch etwas
stärker dazu zum binden
vielleicht mit anbraten lassen damit
gemüsebrühe ablöschen etwas orangensaft
rein für die säure balsamico und
sojasauce das lasse ich die soße hier
kurz aufkochen und leicht einbrechen und
wirkt in der zwischenzeit schon mal die
karotten hobeln in feine streifen und
immer schön mit finger schutz
das wasser salz jetzt noch ein bisschen
und um jetzt zeit zu sparen lege ich
jetzt nudeln hier in eine schüssel und
überließ es dem kochenden wasser ihr
könnt natürlich auch ein wasserkocher
nehmen aber ich habe den workshop
draußen gehabt und dann müssen sie laut
packungsanleitung einfach nur vier
minuten quellen
danach kann ich so abgießen und sie sind
fertig und in der pfanne kann ich jetzt
das übrige fett erhitzen und zuerst die
möhren anbraten
wir brauchen nämlich etwas länger aber
ich möchte dass das ganze gemüse noch
bis hat daher alles wirklich nur ganz
kurz schränken
[Musik]
damit die zucchini mit rein auch ein
bisschen mit schränken die nudeln nicht
vergessen und die soße da was ganz
vergessen
uns war das schicken und dann am besten
erstmal abschmecken mit salz und pfeffer
erst vorher probieren denn ich hab mir
sojasauce drin und gemüsebrühe also kann
es schon sein dass salz ausreicht der
kann gehe ich trotzdem schon mal dazu
die nudeln einmal gut durchrühren
[Musik]
jetzt geht es schon mal die soße direkt
zum gemüse
jetzt gehe ich den faktor hier noch mit
in die pfanne und der hat wirklich eine
ganz kurze garzeit also da wirklich nur
kurz darauf achten mit erhitzen und
fertig da kommen jetzt die nudeln auch
noch mit rein
so sieht doch wunderbar aus
[Musik]
jetzt ist alles fertig ich habe den
grillkäse übrigens in einer
beschichteten pfanne angebraten
funktionell perfekt habe ich richtig
schöne große würfel
hier habe ich an mein gemüse möchte ich
noch ganz kurz abschmecken mit salz und
kalk aber nicht so viel denn die wird
bekommt vom käse hier habe ich jetzt
einfach noch kurzes fleisch unter
wirklich so kurz vor dem verzehr
und es war ja eben noch nicht durch das
heißt jetzt sieht es noch mal schon ok
habe probiert man es ja kaum kaum einmal
rum
ich bin die note und sind einfach so
schön ist nur immer nur bis man bei
alles aus der pfanne bekommt so ein
bisschen gemüse fleisch und käse haben
wir nämlich mit dem heraus und für
obendrauf dachte ich so ist das und
frühlingszwiebeln ich bin gespannt auf
die schmeckt ich hätte auch stäbchen
wollen können bestätigt so gut ist der
gci steche ich immer rein häufig um
troja mache ich auch immer ja ich mag
das hat auch nicht beim essen gefilmt zu
werden
ich glaube es geht jedem so vor allem
auf hochzeiten da kommt jemand der
kameramann und dann gibt's oft kamera
verbot beim essen und sehr würzig und
perfektes kündigt zuschauer vor allem
glaube ich nicht die nudeln die sind ja
so eine weiche konsistenz bis haben sie
noch wann das gemüse zarte fleisch und
dann für dieser krise die kruste ist
nämlich richtig cool
irgendwann kommt er gut raus zum alter
käse sehr gut wenn ihr das rezept nach
machen wollte das wirklich ein richtig
cooles rezept dann schaut doch mal aufs
ellis - blog.de vorbei macht mal nach
postet es auf instagram oder facebook
verlinkt uns dabei und wir schauen uns
gerne eure ergebnisse an
also viel spaß beim nachkochen und bis
zum nächsten mal tschüss und wenn ihr
gerne wok gerichte haben möchte schreibt
gerne in die kommentare
[Musik]